bon alors mélangés de faire un
questionnaire donc faire spécial pour
toi je te jure
enfin en mêlant tu vas voir comment je
vais te donner un exemple je mettrai pas
la team c'est très gentil une première
question mais vraiment la question ton
type est ce que tu préfères trompé
ajoute amer mais gimont
voilà déjà trouvé la question font par
définition c'est celle à laquelle on ne
peut pas répond le germain jti répondu
ouais deuxième question compte c'est là
tu vois que tu pourras pas dire les le
est ce que tu préfères vivre disant très
très très très riche vraiment avec tout
ce que tu veux jade et 747
enfin voilà ou alors sans enfant pauvre
s'entend pas avec un mec super 8 c'est
sûr il va alors troisième question qu'on
est ce que tu serais prête à mourir là
maintenant ça tu meurs
juste après la première tumeur pour que
un million de petits éthiopien puisse
survivre mais c'est comme ça il est
question ça pourrait s'appeler questions
encore l'être
comic con qui parce que c'est vraiment
ses petits enfants ses deux
petits-enfants dit jack locke
imagine tu as plus de pognon t'as plus
rien leur donner à manger sont vraiment
je vais les faire d'un attrait nord qui
sait dire que les accidents ces pauvres
enfants pour les bouddhistes
est ce que tu es vendent de la drogue à
la sortie des écoles oui pour tes
enfants puissent survivre parce que tu
le ferais ça c'est la question qu'ont
par excellence je préfère les vendre sur
les politiques pour qui a qui trouvent
sur le plus de circonstances atténuantes
staline hitler polpot bon alors entre
staline et hitler que je préfère c'est
pour visiter lynch comprends très bien
lequel dix ont tué ses trois dictateurs
lequel tu excuses le plus des pros
staline hitler au pôle paul meningaud
l'imaginer ce problème tu leur parles tu
penses que c'est un psychopathe il y
cinq ans aux seniors
moi j'aurais dit parce que ce sont des
biens volés cléon gras bon alors je
continue
quelle race ses vertus les jaunes les
blancs les noirs ou les rouges qu'est-ce
que tu préfèrerais
et sourde muette aveugle première
solution
ou alors avoir les quatre membres coupés
à ras la pression sur mu est aveugle
première solution deuxième année quatre
mondes combat rassure tu peux quand même
regarder la télé tu peux regarder
sabatier sakho écoute je ne sais pas là
tu vois je vais maintenant tu es seul tu
es seul dans un refuge de montagne perdu
à huit jours de marches de du premier
être vivant
1 et puis tu as envie de faire l'amour
c'est pas moi c'est dans ce refuge mon
engagement est alors imagine bien à ce
moment-là qu'est ce que tu préférerais
faire l'amour avec une femme pas qu'une
car ça lui même sex-toy qu'aucune femme
camilla
voilà ou alors se masturber a laissé
comme s'avère assez consternante
personnes avaient répondu non non non si
tu devais vraiment toujours pas été dans
le refuge était avec un très bon ami
cette fois et y meurent de froid est-ce
que tu commences la touraine et wade est
ce que c'est que de montrer par contre
pas manger le doigt ou la gym
j'ai rien à bouffer tout en intégrant ce
bar le jambon à toi moi je commençais
par la juge par l'ajout fait signer mais
j'ai aussi simone matin pour coter et
dans la pièce autant à faire par rapport
à marie ah oui d'accord je suis son mari
cher monsieur
oui je peux vous dire c'est pas facile